so um so we're here at the wetlands park
and unfortunately multiple times
most years we do have these wildfires
that start up
so this is the first one we've had this
year
i'm told it was approximately 45 acres
in size
and it occurred right behind here in the
nature preserve
so unfortunately a lot of habitat burned
we have a lot of wildlife out here
beavers raccoons
birds so unfortunately i'm sure we lost
some of their their habitats
and then we also lost some some really
nice
trees and and shrubs that really make
the wetlands park special
do we know yet what started the fire so
i don't think they finished their
investigation and we haven't heard yet
but oftentimes these are started by you
know just
just people but it's undetermined at
this time
i know you said 45 acres burned how many
acres is the park
total so the entire park is 2 900 acres
but the nature preserve right here is
only 210 acres so we lost about 25
percent of the nature preserve last
night
were any structures in danger of hitting
fire
so what's what's really great is we have
a nice partnership
with the blm wildland firefighters
and clark county fire department so we
provide them maps for access into all of
these areas we provide them the
locations of structures bridges
shade structures restrooms all of that
so they had that information and they
knew which areas to protect so
thankfully they protected the homes
which is of course the most important
thing
and no other structures were impacted so
they did a really good job
at protecting infrastructure last night
from previous you know burns
and going forward how it affects the
natural uh resource so unfortunately you
know
fires are part of of the ecosystem and
you know a lot more fires are occurring
we've had these every year
at the wetlands park and we have a
partnership with blm nevada division of
forestry national park service
to actually install fuel brakes fuel
reduction programs
and so both of the all of those agencies
are out here working right now to help
reduce the fuel load
so when when these fires do occur we are
prepared to come back in and do some
restoration
afterwards fire is bad for habitat and
wildlife
but then you do get that natural
regeneration so we take advantage of
these opportunities because it does
clear out some of the fuel to go
in and plant so you know it's it's it's
it's devastating for the habitat but it
does provide opportunities for us to
improve uh the landscape so that we have
fuels out there that that won't quite
carry the fire like this again
anything else you'd like to add just you
know
you know the wind didn't probably help
things i'm sure
so actually i was talking with the fire
department and
fortunately you know this didn't happen
a few days earlier
and because the winds actually shifted
in direction
they were able to keep um they're able
to do some back burning
and move the the fuel away from the
houses so actually it worked in their
favor last night and that doesn't always
happen
okay now we're seeing people out here
but are
some of the trails here at the uh
the nature preserve are they closed now
so when things like this happen
um so last night fortunately the park
was already closed
so they were able to do the work that
they needed to do
um today they they're temporarily
closing
certain areas just as you know they have
little flare-ups
and whatnot but most of the trails are
open but if anybody does come out today
they just need to be cautious
and you know stay on the trails and not
go into the burn
you said a lot of the areas were damaged
by the fire are they going to be able to
recover
or will they just have to start new ones
in some of the areas that weren't burned
so it's kind of interesting
we've been studying this over the years
that some
plants don't recover but other plants
do so we noticed in the fire that we had
last year about this time that the
mesquites were able to re-sprout
and same thing with some of the
cottonwoods but if the fire gets too
intense
it actually does kill the trees and then
last night you know some of the the
photos were pretty dramatic
and you get that really high flame
length and that's from the
the reeds that are out here and so reeds
are actually they're not native
to this particular park and so
um it's it was kind of worked out to
clear out that fuel load and then we can
come back in and plant trees
so it's it's a mixed bag
what kind of activity can you do here at
the woodlands park
does that affect anybody so
you know over the last year there's been
lots of changes of course
we've had a near 100
increase in visitation out here a lot of
people have been fighting their parks
over the last year
and so here at the wetlands park our
trails are open every day dawn to dusk
there's
bicycling trails there's wildlife
viewing bird
watching there's so much that you can do
out here just to connect with nature and
so
unfortunately this wetlands park burned
last night but it really does
you know bring it back to the forefront
that this is a really wonderful
park that you can come out and with your
family and friends and enjoy
nature in a safe environment
and unfortunately you know our exhibit
gallery is closed right now for obvious
reasons but typically we do have an
indoor facility where you can come in
and see interactive exhibits we offer
programs year-round
right now we're offering virtual
programs only we offer a virtual
field trip we have a wetlands discovery
club
where you can do activities at home and
then come out into the park
and do activities here as well we also
have
water coloring programs and so if you go
to our website at ccwetlandspark.org you
can see
all kinds of information about the park
and ways to
get involved out here
thank you very much